>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Georgette Dorn: Good afternoon,
my name is Georgette Dorn
and I am the Chief of the Hispanic
Division and I'm very pleased
to welcome all of you
to this wonderful event
despite the horrible rainy day.
It is my pleasure to
introduce Catalina Gomez,
a reference librarian and
specialist in Hispanic literature.
Catalina Gomez.
>> Catalina Gomez: Dr. Charlotte
Rogers is assistant professor
of Spanish at the University
of Virginia.
Her book Jungle Fever
exploring madness and medicine
in 20th century tropical
narratives was published in 2012.
In 2014, she was a Kluge fellow
here at the Library of Congress
where she researched her new
book, Project about the Legend
of El Dorado in contemporary
literature of the Americas.
In 2015, Princeton University
awarded her the library research
grant to study its archive
of Mario Llosa paper.
Please join me in welcoming
Charlotte Rogers.
[ Applause ]
>> Charlotte Rogers: Thank you very
much Catalina for your warm words
of welcome and thank you everyone
for coming here today
despite the rain.
I'm really honored to be here,
particularly in this room
because I hope you have a chance
to look around while you're here.
There's some [inaudible]
over there in the corner
and while we were setting up for
this event they were playing them.
Because I have to kind of give
them a good workout every once
in a while.
Also, the Library of Congress
is a very special place
and I have loved it ever since
I was a Kluge fellow here
and I particularly fell in love
with the Hispanic Division
and its resources.
So for all of those reasons it's
a very special privilege for me
to speak to you today
about Alvaro Mutis.
As a Colombian poet and novelist
Mutis was often overshadowed
by his friend and compatriot,
Gabriel Garcia Marquez.
Scholars often compare them even
though their work is completely
different just because they were
from the same place and they ended
up living next-door to each
other in Mexico City in exile.
So what I'm going to
propose to do here today goes
against that tradition of constantly
comparing Mutis and Garcia Marquez.
I'm actually going to do a sort of
literary contrapuntal or a point
and counter point that compares
not Mutis and Garcia Marquez,
but actually Mutis and
Miguel de Cervantes,
perhaps a much more
surprising comparison.
So I've chosen this musical
contrapuntal structure
for a couple of reasons.
First, the juxtaposition
between Cervantes and Mutis,
who is shown here with
a cocktail which I love.
I hope my next book has a name of
a cocktail in the author photo.
So in comparing these two great
authors I want to pay homage
to Mutis and really put him on
the same level with Cervantes,
which I think is a bold claim.
Second, I am paying a very
personal tribute to Edith Grossman
who is the translator of adventures
and misadventures of Maqroll,
as well as Don Quixote by Cervantes.
And so as Catalina
mentioned, you have the chance
to buy the Adventures of Maqroll,
which is Edith's translation.
But the last and most
important reason why I want
to compare these two authors is
that there are many affinities
between Mutis and Cervantes
both biographical and literary.
This is so much the case that I
think that Mutis actually wrote
with Cervantes in mind and I'm
going to point out a couple
of places here today where I
think we can see Mutis thinking
about Cervantes.
So this contrapuntal is designed
to highlight those enduring values
and the contemporary
relevance of Alvaro Mutis.
Also, I really just want to
provide points of departure
for our question-and-answer period
because I think that's always
the most illuminating part
of the talk for me.
So to begin due to these accidents
of birth should state the obvious
and these two men clearly belong
to different nations and eras.
But Alvaro Mutis was born in
Bogota in Columbia in 1923.
He took up residence in
Mexico City in the late 1950's
where he died on September
22nd, 2013.
So this is also really a tribute
to him just a few short
years after his passing.
So and of course, I'm sure most of
you know Cervantes lived in Spain
and died in Madrid in 1616.
But despite these differences, the
men share biographical elements
that marked their literary
production.
So I'll give you just
a few examples.
First, both authors showed a really
early preference for writing poetry
and a penchant for more
colorful activities.
Cervantes once wounded
a man in a dual
and Alvaro spent his
free time playing pool,
so much so that he actually
never graduated from high school
because he spent a lot of time
in the billiard hall
and reading novels.
He said Dickens was
one of his favorites.
More importantly, the sea also
plays a large role in the work
of both men and their lives.
Cervantes famously lost an arm in
the 1571 naval battle of Lepanto,
which earned him the epithet
El Manco de Lepanto, you know,
the one armed man from Lepanto.
Now in a less military way water
imagery is an essential part
of Mutis' prose in poetry.
Throughout this talk I'm
going to point out a couple
of aquatic motifs, I think
that really marked Mutis.
And we're going to start
doing that by listening to one
of Mutis' poems that features water.
So you're going to have to bear
with me here as I sneak out.
We're going to listen to
a poem called Nocturno,
there it'll show here.
So this poem is called Nocturno from
Los trabajos perdidos from 1965.
And as Catalina mentioned, all of
this is available on the website
of the Library of Congress.
So we're going to just play
right off the internet here.
And I should mention I'm going
to be reading translations
of Mutis' prose work, but I've left
his poetry in the original Spanish.
So I invite you to close
your eyes and listen to Mutis
as he reads his own
work, this is Nocturno.
[ Speaking Foreign Language ]
So I hope that you can hear
that cascade of water, you know,
falling over the coffee
plants in the poem
and that brings a very cleansing
[foreign language] knowing the words
of Mutis.
So water also appears in
Mutis' prose, you know,
always as a cleansing
or liberating image.
In fact, Mutis' most famous literary
character is also a sailor right.
The peripatetic and melancholic
mariner named Maqroll el Gaviero.
And I think that there is
a great similarity there,
actually between Cervantes
and Mutis in the sense
that both men created a literary
or a fictional person
who outlives them right.
You all know about Don Quixote
he's become an iconic figure,
but I argue that Mutis' character
Maqroll should be just as famous.
So Maqroll appears in a series
of seven short novels collected
in English as we mentioned
as the Adventures
and Misadventures of Maqroll.
And in those novels the eponymous
protagonist travels the world right,
on a variety of unsuccessful quests.
So I think you can see
some similarities already
between Maqroll el
Gaviero and Don Quixote.
But I think we should
go a bit deeper,
so let's start looking very closely
at his name, Maqroll el Gaviero.
Maqroll Mutis stated in lots
of interviews is actually
his own invention,
it's a made-up name though he wanted
to give a vaguely Scottish flavor,
which you can hear with
the Maq in the Maqroll.
Yet Maqroll is also intended to
be of inscrutable origin right.
Mutis never reveals
his country of birth.
He speaks multiple languages and the
reader learns only that he traveled
on a fake passport
from Cypress right.
So it gives you an idea of a
shady past in his background.
In reality, I like to argue that his
[foreign language] is the sea right.
Now his nickname el Gaviero is also
an explicitly nautical reference.
The gavia in Spanish
means the jib right,
it's one of the sails
on a large ship.
And the gaviero is the
sailor who manages it often
from a very high point
up on the mast right,
so it's kind of a lookout
point as well.
So in her translation Edie Grossman
has very ghastly rendered Maqroll's
nickname el gaviero as the lookout.
A title that refers explicitly
to that sailor who perches
up on the crow's nest of the ship
and scans the horizon for dangers.
In fact, this position at the top
of the mast was also known formerly
as the carajo if you'll excuse my
rather vulgar language here okay.
So being in the carajo was
not very highly desired
because of the wind and the rain.
And that and this may
be a folk etymology,
but as far as I've been
able to tell that post,
that nautical post gave rise to
the expression vete el carajo,
which now has the meaning that all
of you are thinking of right now.
So when we take these two aspects
of the name together Maqroll
and gaviero evokes a traveler with
a capacity for self-invention right.
He's employed in a rather
antiquated profession
and he contemplates the
vastness of the ocean
and the depths of human folly.
So Maqroll and Don Quixote
in this counterpoint
that I'm doing are
actually very similar.
If we remember that Alonzo Quijano
also invents himself as Don Quixote.
He too takes up an
antiquated profession right,
that of knight errant
and he also travels
over the vast landscape
of La Mancha.
In another sense I think that
both characters are really
from nowhere right, in the sense
that Maqroll has no fixed home.
Don Quixote is from La Mancha,
which is so arid and boring
that it's like being from nowhere.
But I think great things
can come from nowhere.
And each character always sets out
right to perform these great feats
and so that's what makes them
similar in their uniqueness.
So let's turn back
now to our authors.
The most significant biographical
similarity between Cervantes
and Mutis is they both spent a
formative period of time in jail.
They were imprisoned for what
we would call today white-collar
crimes right.
Cervantes was involved in
disputes in his very odious job
as a tax collector and as a result
he was incarcerated several times.
In 1956, Mutis was working in
public relations for Standard Oil,
which is now known as Exxon.
When he was accused of embezzling
company funds he fled to Mexico.
And from there Mutis fought
the extradition process back
to Columbia, but the Mexican
officials detained him for 15 months
in what is known as the --
oh sorry, there's the books
that we're working with here.
So he was detained for 15
months in the black palace
of the Lecumberri also
known as El Palacios Negro.
It's one of the most notorious,
it was one of the most
notorious prisons in Mexico.
And since 1978 it's actually
housed the archives in Mexico,
so I think there's an amazing
coincidence there between writing
in the written word and
imprisonment, which often gives rise
to really great works of literature.
So the charges against
Mutis were later dropped
and they were largely attributed
to the political wrangling
of the Colombian dictator,
Gustavo Rojas Pinilla at the time.
But nevertheless, Mutis spent 15
months in Lecumberri and I think
that that had a very powerful
effect on his later literature.
So in fact, these harsh
experiences turned out to be a boon
for both men's literary creations.
Cervantes writes in the prologue
to part one of the Quixote
that the idea for his
great work came to him
in the jail of Seville right.
Any of you have seen The Man of
La Mancha the music you'll know
that it starts with
Cervantes in prison.
But Mutis also found
inspiration there.
He published a few short vignettes
about his time in Lecumberri
and it's called Lecumberri Diary.
The best image that Moody's
Mutis creates in that diary is
yet again an aquatic motif right.
He envisions a torrential rain
similar to the one we heard earlier
that will flood the prison
and it fills him with hope.
In this instance water imagery
indicates freedom right.
Seas, rivers, rains all
symbolized liberty for Mutis.
And he hopes that it will
carry him out floating
onto the vast floodwaters and it
will and I quote from the diary,
leave behind judges,
ministers, scribes, guards,
and all the other beasts
that cling to human flesh
and blindly beat their
heads against us
in a furious attempt to destroy us.
So in the rest of his life's work
Mutis would deplore the injustice
and the incompetence of
bureaucratic ordeals.
Cervantes similarly critiqued the
holy brotherhood and the suffering
of the galley slaves in the
Quixote if we can recall.
These bleak prison stints turned
out to be what Mutis calls [foreign
language] okay [foreign language].
Fertile misery for both men
because their novels exhibit a very
deep sympathy for single individuals
and an equally deep skepticism
towards the possibility
of justice in human society.
So in addition to formative
prison time both men turned away
from poetry and towards prose
very late in their life.
In fact, their masterpieces
came when they were
in their late 50's and early 60's.
Cervantes was 58 when he published
the Quixote, Mutis was in his 60's
and retired from publicity work
at that multinational corporation
when he wrote that seven
series of novellas.
And I find that very inspiring
right, for all of us to think
that we all have a great literary
masterpiece inside us that may come
out when we're, you know, retired.
You know, getting closer
towards the last portion of life.
So up to this point I talked about
the biographical similarities
between Cervantes and Mutis.
Yeah, I think the more important
question is really do they share a
literary vision.
I argue that yes and we can see
their common esthetic in two ways.
The first one and they're both --
they're related elements right.
The first one is a
very keen perception
of the folly of human endeavors.
The second is a profound
sense of disillusionment
or [foreign language] as
it's known in Spanish.
These contrasting sentiments,
a dark humor
and an ironic wistful bitterness are
really two sides of the same coin.
So that underneath
the traveling romps
of their protagonists lies a harsh
and biting critique of the era
in which each author lived.
And a reflection on the fleeting
nature of human existence.
You know, both of them
having suffered so much.
But first let's start
with the fun stuff.
So we're going to look
at human folly okay.
Cervantes I'm going to ask you to
remember or imagine the Quixote
and just in case you haven't read it
we don't have that for sale today,
but I think you can find a few
copies here in the library.
So let's look at folly.
You can think a very famous scene
in the Quixote in a roadside inn,
which features a hunchbacked
girl named Maritornes
and she's a servant.
And Cervantes says she is
the [foreign language] right.
So he says she's blind in one eye
and care barely see
out of the other.
However, Maritornes in addition
to being a servant is supposed
to offer her nocturnal services
to a mule driver who is staying
in the same room as Don
Quixote and Sancho in the end.
So when Maritornes comes into the
room it's dark and she stumbles
around and she suddenly ends
up in the arms of Don Quixote.
Now she's wearing burlap
and she smells
of rotten salad [foreign
language] right.
But the night errant, you
know, in his madness believes
that she's a beautiful princess
and he starts wooing her fervently
in the middle of the night.
This wakes up the mule driver
who goes into a jealous rage
and beats Don Quixote
to a pulp right.
In the meantime Maritornes
is hiding under the bed
and when Sancho discovers her
she beats him up again right.
So there's a lot of very
physical comedy in the Quixote,
but really I think
Cervantes is pointing out as
with Mutis the ridiculous
ironies of male desire right.
And the ability to suspend
your disbelief right,
in pursuit of desire.
So let's look at how Mutis
does the same thing okay.
I want to highlight Mutis'
perhaps his most famous novel
from the Maqroll series it's
Ilona Llega Con La Lluvia okay.
Ilona comes with the rain.
It was also made into a
motive, which is very famous.
And again, I want to point out we
can see the importance of water here
in the alliterative title of the
book Ilona Llega Con La Lluvia.
So the Ilona of the title is
Maqroll's companion and lover
who he happens to reencounter
in Panama
after a long time they spent apart.
Ilona convinces Maqroll that they
should start a brothel in order
to make enough money to
leave Panama and to continue
on her adventures together.
Now what's special about this
brothel according to Ilona,
is that the prostitutes all appear
to be foreign airline stewardesses
on a layover in Panama okay.
So I teach this novel to my
undergraduates they're scandalized,
but the most important thing is that
they understand since they were born
in the late 90's right, they
don't understand why stewardesses
or [foreign language] were seen
as something exotic or desirable.
So for me the hardest part of
teaching this that I have to explain
to them that air travel used to be
seen as this pleasant luxury right
and that having sex workers look
like stewardesses actually
lent a very cosmopolitan
and sophisticated air to
what is really a very sordid
and ancient commercial
enterprise okay.
So Ilona in particular gleefully
exploits male gullibility.
She spends a lot of time
fabricating these uniforms.
She concocts exotic back stories
for these very average employees,
they're all local girls,
but they pretend
to be from more exotic places.
I mean everyone enjoys
playing a role
in some way I think we see some
echoes of Don Quixote here.
So that's how Mutis
really highlights the folly
of male desires.
Yet, I'd like to talk about one
more very serious similarity
to Cervantes in this novel.
So one of Ilona and Maqroll's
employee named Larissa has gone
completely insane.
She has been driven
mad by reading right.
For several years prior
to her employment she
constantly read stories
about the Napoleonic era.
And now in the novel she believes
that she is visited every night
by French and Italian soldiers
to whom she makes love.
Now it is clear in the narrative
that these soldiers are
actually ghosts right
and that she is tormented
and she eventually --
well I won't spoil the ending
for you, but it doesn't end well.
So in essence, she
has been driven mad
by literature just
like Don Quixote right.
So Alonso Quijano before he's
Don Quixote, Alonso Quijano reads
so much that and I'm quoting
here from Edie's translation,
his brains dried up and his
fantasy filled with everything
that he had read in his books.
Now Mutis is clearly thinking of
Cervantes here in creating Larissa.
The similarities between Don Quixote
and Larissa are made even
more obvious by the fact
that Larissa lives on a
houseboat called El Lepanto right,
which recalls that same naval battle
where Cervantes lost his arm on.
Moreover, Maqroll is also a
quixotic figure because he too stays
up all night reading medieval
histories of French battles
and he declares that he
is and I quote living
in a time completely alien
to my interests and tastes.
So for both Maqroll and Don Quixote
literature is more compelling
than reality okay.
Now, I mentioned that both writers
exhibit a sense of disenchantment
with their current
societies, so that's sort
of the darker side of things here.
For example, in Ilona arrives
with the rain Maqroll grows bored
of running the brothel when
he realizes that and I quote,
prostitution is just as
conventional as marriage.
This is again where my
students kind of explode
and they have a really hard
time discussing this okay.
So why are they the same?
Maqroll says both are made
up of suffocating routines,
trivial stories and
calculated meanness.
Now I think that Maqroll has
become a beloved Latin American
literary figure.
I can't tell you how many
of my scholarly friend sign
their e-mail signatures
with a Mutis quote right,
from some Maqroll story.
Things just like-- mine
though does not prostitution
as conventional as marriage.
I think my husband he would
probably try to translate that
and I don't think he'd
appreciate that very much.
But this is why we love
Maqroll right, he rejects all
of the accepted morays, he
hates geographical fixity,
he despises bourgeois mentality.
So if we want to live like
Maqroll how we can avoid these
suffocating routines.
Mutis indicates Maqroll's refusal to
stay in one place and his rejection
of material goods frees him right.
Just much like Don Quixote he's
able to travel as he pleases.
Mutis' early poetry also shows the
same thirst for new experiences.
So right now I'm going to read one
of his early prose
poems called Los viajes.
I'm going to read it in Spanish
so you can hear the rhythms
and if you don't speak
Spanish you can think
about maybe learning while
I read this out loud.
No, but really you can listen to
the rhythms of Mutis' poetry here.
So [inaudible].
[ Speaking Foreign Language ]
So you can hear there some
of the same aquatic motifs I was
mentioning, but I think we also hear
from this poem, which is from 1993
before Mutis went to prison or lived
in exile you can hear its
youthful excitement right.
It's wonder at imaginary
and natural worlds there.
It's also a meta-literary
poem because those of you
who have studied French or Hispanic
literature know that it sounds a lot
like Charles Baudelaire Les Fleurs
du mal right, the flowers of evil.
There's a famous phrase one of those
poems that says go out in search
of the unknown right, it doesn't
matter if it's hell or heaven go
in search of the unknown.
So I hear a strong echo of
that 19th century poet here.
So in fact, I would say that
the inspiration for travel,
for adventure, for Maqroll and also
for Don Quixote always
comes from reading right.
There's a very close
relationship between the text
and the voyage here okay.
So I'd like to mention one other
way in which Mutis pays homage
to Cervantes in some
meta-literary homage.
In the Snow of the Admiral
or La Nieve del Almirante,
which is the first in
the Maqroll series.
Mutis eludes to Cervantes
in the very way
in which he structures
the narrative.
So at the beginning of
the novel we're thinking
of La Nieve del Almirante a frame
narrator finds Maqroll's diary
and it's written on scraps of paper.
These old scraps of paper
have been tucked into a volume
of French history,
which the narrator finds
in an antiquarian bookstore
in Barcelona okay.
So this complicated narrative device
is called the found manuscript.
And it echoes the way that
Cervantes frames the Quixote very
famously right.
In the Quixote the narrator ends
up buying a part of the novel
that we read on, which is
actually been written in Arabic
and we read it in translation right.
And it's been written in Arabic
on the backs of old papers right,
in a particular neighborhood
in Toledo, in Spain.
So again, we can see very clearly
that Mutis is making a reference
to Cervantes here in a
meta-literary beginning.
And he does this because Mutis
like Cervantes wants to say
that his tale is as much about
literature itself as it is
about the idea of travel
right and adventure.
So to wrap up this portion I want to
say that both authors are fascinated
by that active storytelling
because it shows off the capacity
of literature to transport
and transform us right.
Transform the authors,
the protagonists
and the readers altogether.
So reading is a transformative
experience.
So let's return now to that sense of
disenchantment or [foreign language]
that I mentioned earlier.
Both Maqroll and Don Quixote
would rather live in literature
than in their contemporary
reality and some
of us may feel the same way.
As a result, when the literary
characters are confronted
with this yawning chasm
between their literary reveries
and their quotidian realities
they become nostalgic
for an imagined past right.
They're nostalgic not for
what they've lived before,
but what they have read about right,
they want to live in
a literary world.
There's also a sense that both
authors think their protagonist's
best days are behind on.
I think that may come
from the late time in life
in which both authors
wrote their works.
So the second part of the Quixote,
which was published in 1615 right,
portrays Spain in [foreign language]
right, the decline of Spain
with a wasteful aristocracy
and a bureaucracy.
And even right before he dies
Don Quixote comes to his senses
as Alonso Quijano and he suffers
an extreme form of disenchantment.
He repudiates all of
his adventures okay.
So he is disenchanted
with the notion
of performing great feats right
and it's a very sad ending.
And the reader is also left with
that sense of disillusionment,
with the Spanish Empire,
with adventure,
with literature, and altogether.
Now in a similar fashion
in the Snow of the Admiral,
La Nieve del Almirante
Maqroll is very skeptical
about the values of
the contemporary era.
He decries and I quote, people
dedicated to working like mules
for that empty thing
they call progress.
Most disheartening of all
Maqroll is an adventurer in an age
without new places
to discover right.
When I think of Google Earth I
realize there are very few places
now that we can't just zoom in on
and get a close satellite photo of.
So in the Snow of the Admiral the
mariner confesses and I quote,
a growing discouragement and lack of
interest in travel and life itself.
I think this is why John Updike in
one of his excellent book reviews
in the New Yorker wrote that Maqroll
was a latter-day Don Quixote.
So Maqroll and Don
Quixote are both wanderers
who ultimately critique the
societies that they live in.
Indeed Maqroll's disillusionment
is a very contemporary form
of Cervantian [foreign language]
and I think that is the hallmark
of Mutis' literary aesthetic
despite all the ridiculous folly
and adventures he has, you know,
at heart there is a very deep place
of sadness and disenchantment
there right.
Ultimately, Don Quixote
and Maqroll are thwarted
in their attempts to travel.
They don't accomplish
the great feats
of bravery that they set out to do.
I think that each author depicts a
society, be it 17th-century Spain
or late 20th-century Latin America
in which great adventures
are impossible
and even ridiculous right.
Don Quixote is literally loaded
onto a cart and driven home
at the end of part one right.
Maqroll too repeatedly embarks and
adventures that lead to failure.
When Maqroll is left penniless
and hopeless after one
of these adventures he
concludes and I quote,
I spent my whole life setting
out on this kind of adventure
and finding the same
disillusionment at the end.
Although I console myself with
the thought that the reward was
in the adventure itself and there's
no reason to search for anything
but the satisfaction of trying
every one of the world's roads.
They all start looking
suspiciously alike.
And yet they're worth
traveling if only
to stave off tedium
in our own death.
So this is one of the
enduring values
in contemporary relevance
of Cervantes and Mutis.
They both recognize that travels and
readings just serve to distract us
from the inevitability of death.
In fact, many of Mutis' poems
confront the subject of death
and I'm going to conclude here
today by analyzing just one of them
as a way to remember
Mutis' passing in 2013.
So we're going to look
at three lines
from a poem called Poema de lastimas
a la muerte de Marcel Proust.
So as the title suggests
the poem laments the death
of the French poet Proust,
the French novelist excuse me,
Marcel Proust who suffered
from asthma
and died of pneumonia in 1922.
This poem was written in the
Lecumberri prison in 1956
and Mutis is undoubtedly
contemplating his own demise
as well.
Mutis describes Proust's last
asthmatic breath here when he says.
[ Foreign Language ]
So I am haunted by this image
here and I hope you are too
of the poet attempting to
free himself attempting,
attempting to breathe while
a gravestone is pressing
down on his chest right.
So you have that connection
between asthma and the, you know,
the proximity of death
symbolized by the grave.
It's very powerful.
Mutis further envisions death
for Proust as a nostalgic limbo
where his literary creations,
which he calls criaturas
or creatures here are
waiting for him.
So here he says and
he's thinking of Proust,
but I think he's thinking
of himself here too.
[ Speaking Foreign Language ]
So we readers right are
left thinking of Maqroll
as the creature awaiting Mutis
on the shores of time right.
Just like Proust created his
novelistic creations we also
have Mutis.
The richness of Mutis' novelistic
and poetic worlds are our
consolation as readers right.
When we're devastated by as Mutis
says of Proust we're devastated by.
[ Speaking Foreign Language ]
So Mutis' tribute to Proust I
think expresses what we as admirers
of his work now feel for
the Colombian author right.
Death may await us all, but
this writer's legacy lives on.
So thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
So now my favorite part questions
and please do use the microphone
if you'd like to ask some questions.
I look forward to it.
>> Does your interest in
these characters [inaudible]
that are doomed to failure.
That sounds not just like
[inaudible] can be incorporated
into your own realm of books?
>> Charlotte Rogers: Thank you Tom.
Tom was an excellent
reference librarian
who helped while I was a Kluge
fellow here working on a book I have
in progress about the
Legend of El Dorado
in contemporary Latin America.
And as a matter of fact, Mutis is
one of the authors that I study
in my book project
called Morning El Dorado.
Because in the Snow of the Admiral,
one of the novels I mentioned,
Maqroll travels up a river in search
of a sawmill that he thinks is going
to make him a lot of money.
But the interesting thing
about the sawmill is
that it is described
using language similar
to what the Spanish conquistador
several hundred years earlier used
to describe El Dorado.
So it has a golden halo, it glimmers
and shimmers in a distance, it hums,
and it's completely inaccessible
and he's never allowed in
and he's shipped off back downriver
without completing his quest right.
So I think that there are
echoes there of Cervantes,
but also of the notion of the
search for a terrestrial paradise,
a more general idea of
utopia or that no place
where perfection exists kind
of in Thomas Moore's idea.
So yes, Mutis in La Nieve
del Almirante is just one
of those unsuccessful quests where
we also see the notion of the quest
for El Dorado as a failure.
So thank you Tom.
>> Thank you Professor Rogers,
my name is John Del
Pino [assumed spelling],
I'm directing my comments
[inaudible].
First off, I'd like
to say [inaudible].
May I say [inaudible] an
exquisitely eloquent presentation.
>> Charlotte Rogers: Thank you.
>> That your unique blend of
certain phrases was [inaudible] say
that first of all.
And also, [inaudible] my family is
from Colombia [inaudible] a few days
ago by happenstance [inaudible].
Actually I never heard
about [inaudible].
And I'm very, very glad [inaudible]
and your presentation of it,
but also some Mutisian
themes that you stressed.
And it is very [inaudible]
Cervantes and Maqroll and others.
So the [inaudible] as far as the
[inaudible] I'm sure [inaudible].
But I want to ask [inaudible]
and provoked [inaudible].
But I'd like to add a little brief
spin on it that my favorite person
in history and writing, you
know, is Winston Churchill.
And I'm [inaudible] political
discussion [inaudible] living beyond
oneself [inaudible] like
for love for example.
And I'm not sure [inaudible]
explore this whether explicitly
or [inaudible].
But the idea [inaudible]
quest for adventure all
by themselves and [inaudible].
I mean, a famous poem [inaudible]
wing to wing or the idea
that [inaudible] travel like
[inaudible] in flight wing
to wing order with the
idea that [inaudible].
And I understand some people
be frowned upon [inaudible].
I think Churchill is
really [inaudible] kind
of roundtable saying [inaudible]
who you were [inaudible].
And it kind of [inaudible].
And finally [inaudible]
wife and said,
I'm not who I am I wish I
was second Mr. Churchill.
That's how much his wife
meant to him [inaudible].
Even his final last words
were the [inaudible].
Because he loves his
wife so much [inaudible].
And I think actually [inaudible].
Thank you.
>> Charlotte Rogers: Great, thank
you very much for your question.
I think that you're touching
on some important points.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yeah, no I think you're touching
on some important points,
especially the universality
of the human --
the idea of the quest right that
we see in all different kinds
of literature from the
Odyssey up into, you know,
Mutis I would say is a very
post-modern look at the quest.
And many critics also read Mutis as
an existential hero in many ways.
There's one point in Ilona Llega
Con La Lluvia and Ilona comes
with the rain where Ilona looks
at Maqroll and says to him
in French [foreign language]
right, which the die has cast.
Which is also the title of a very
famous play by John Paul Sartre.
So I have seen some great
student papers comparing Maqroll
to Sisyphus right and the idea
of that existential crisis
of even though that we
know that we're all going
to die how are we going to
make our lives meaningful right
and how are we going to
continue in that struggle.
And I think that's why
Maqroll continues his journeys.
And it's knowing that --
he has a line about knowing
that no matter what happens you're
always going to accept your destiny
and make something of it,
you know, while you're going.
And so I think that for
Maqroll and I think for Mutis
in some ways living well was
part of that resistance to death.
I was talking with Edith Grossman,
his translator, who knew him well
and said that he always had the best
food, the best liquor, you know,
he would have these
long literary evenings
in Mexico City with Garcia Marquez.
So I think that, especially
for someone who has suffered
in prison or, you know,
has confronted political
exile I think the notion
of living well is a
form of resisting death.
So that's what I would
certainly take from Alvaro.
So thank you.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yeah, yeah.
>> So I'm curious about this
relationship that Mutis had
with water [inaudible] such a,
you know, [inaudible] rivers
and the two oceans [inaudible].
Where in Columbia, where did
he travel around the country
and if this encounter with
so much water [inaudible].
>> Charlotte Rogers: Yeah,
I think that we see water
in several different ways, you
know, both with the sea and Maqroll,
but also in particular with the
rain that we hard in Nocturno
and especially the rain
on the [foreign language],
on the coffee plants.
Which I think that because
Mutis grew up in his early years
in Brussels because his father was a
diplomat I think there was something
about a rediscovery
of the Colombian earth
and the Colombian waterways
in particular.
For example in La Nieve
del Almirante,
in the Snow of the
Admiral, Maqroll travels
up a fictional river
called the [inaudible],
but there's a very well-known Mutis
scholar named Consuelo Hernandez
who is at American
University who has identified,
you know, which river that is.
But I don't think it's a
particularly Colombian motif
and that's because Mutis traveled
-- I think he traveled, you know,
30 or 40 weeks a year when he
was working in public relations
and so he has written
about the Baltic Sea.
And he has written about Trieste,
he's written about the
Mediterranean, you know,
I think that he's a writer you
have to read with a map in hand.
And so the aquatic
metaphor comes up not just
in Columbia, but all over the place.
Although, I think the most
interesting thing about Maqroll,
however, is that all of his
adventures happen on land.
You know, because he remembers times
being at sea, but if you're going
to have adventures he
attempts to be more earthbound.
And that's what he's
looking to escape right,
to get back on the river.
So that's a great question though
I would love to see more written
about water in the Maqroll series.
>> [Inaudible] anymore questions?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Thanks Ryan.
>> It was interesting to think
about Don Quixote [inaudible].
>> Charlotte Rogers: Right.
>> [Inaudible], so I was
wondering these critiques
about novels [inaudible].
How do their historic contexts
[inaudible] use the word postmodern
novel [inaudible]?
How are their historical
contexts [inaudible]?
>> Charlotte Rogers:
Yeah, thank you very much.
Ryan is an excellent
scholar of Mutis as well.
So I would actually love to hear
him answer the question too,
but I'll go first.
So in all the different
critiques and analyses of Mutis
that I've seen there is a divide.
Some people really see him
as a pre-modern hero right,
especially when he says he lives
in a time that's [foreign language]
right, which is alien to him.
So some people see him
as a pre-modern old-school
hero in that sense.
I totally disagree.
Actually, I do think
that he is postmodern,
especially because if we look
at like Francois Leotard's idea
of being disenchanted
with the material
and economic gains of modernism.
That didn't happen right
much of Latin America.
And so I think Maqroll and sorry,
Mutis shows through Maqroll a
deep sense of disenchantment
with people working
like mules right,
for that thing that
they call progress.
So I see in a very Latin
American context a disenchantment
with the idea of [foreign
language] as Brazil says right,
the idea that that's
just not happening.
Now Mutis is not unique in that
sense, I think he's writing
in a long tradition of critiquing
with failed promises of modernity.
With Cervantes I think
that the context is
of course, very different.
I think that Cervantes --
most people see Cervantes,
especially the second
half of Don Quixote
as critiquing the bureaucracy
and aristocracy in Spain.
Spain was deeply in debt
to other European countries
and there was the sense that the
country was running into the ground.
Now I think that that may be an
easy reading in hindsight to make
and I don't know if that was
really what Cervantes was feeling
at the time.
But I mean I think all great
authors critique the moments
that they live in right.
I have a hard time thinking of
any author who doesn't right,
whose work we still read today.
I mean Voltaire does the same
thing for France, you know,
has a similar quest narrative there.
So I think that we can paint with a
broad brush in saying that there's
that sense of disenchantment, but
I agree that it's good to look
at their specific historical
consequences and circumstances.
So do you want to -- do you have an
answer for your own question there?
What do you think?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Oh he's famous for
doing that I know.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Right.
>> And so just kind of curious
about how he goes back a period
long before Cervantes himself,
that's his own [inaudible].
But it seems like the novels
are very much about [inaudible].
And it's interesting to think about
the idea of the nation as Mutis
as well because there
really isn't [inaudible].
>> Charlotte Rogers:
No, no it's okay.
I do think that Mutis is
famous for proclaiming himself
to be monarchist whenever
he's asked about politics.
And I think that idea comes
from his [foreign language] idea
like that's why he says that
marriage is or prostitution is just
as conventional as marriage right,
he wants to shock people and go
against their accepted
idea of what's going on.
I think he also wants to avoid
talking about politics there,
especially living in
exile in Mexico City.
I think he also wants to
echo Maqroll who for him was
like another person in his life
when he says that he's living
in a time that's alien
to his interest.
I think that's a crystallization and
perhaps exaggeration of that idea.
So yeah, I mean Maqroll himself
is certainly against the notion
of power dominating him right,
he wants to be a communist.
But yeah, it's a good quote.
So thank you.
>> I just want to say [inaudible]
make sure you're holding
on cocktail.
>> Charlotte Rogers: Okay,
thank you very much Tom.
>> It's quite the academic
[inaudible] too.
>> Charlotte Rogers:
Yes, I'll be sure --
well I don't know about that,
but thank you very much.
>> Last question.
>> What was his personal life like?
>> Charlotte Rogers:
Well, I mean I know
that he was married
and had children.
I know that he worked for
his entire life in publicity
and that was why -- one
of the reasons why he
traveled around so much.
And I think that is an
important part of his literature.
But he's also unlike a lot of
the very famous boom writers
who are able to make a living
off of their writings right.
Like I said, Mutis didn't retire
until he was in his 60's and that's
when he wrote his novels.
He had been famous for being a
poet before, but he had a 9 to 5
or more just like a lot of us.
So I think that's an inspiring
biographical detail, you know,
that we should all keep
working on our novels
and poetry in our off hours.
>> [Inaudible] thanking Charlotte
for this wonderful lecture.
>> Charlotte Rogers: Thank
you, thank you all for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.